hello everyone uh nice to meet you in
the afternoon I am jinfong Wu I just
graduated graduated a few months ago
from Johns Hopkins University and
currently a postdoc at Samus in the ml
ml research Port
so today I'm gonna talk a little bit
about my research
my research and a few problems in deep
learning theory specifically I will be
talking about the large subsides
gradient descent
so a few words about my research
interests I'm interested in deep
learning theory in particular I'm
interested in the intersection between
statistical learning theory and
optimization in the context of deep
learning to be more specific
so deep learning has
revolutionalized the the Practical
machine learning and and on the other
hand there's also revolutionalized our
understanding of the learning series
itself and optimization so
uh so that's why I'm uh get get very
interested in the theory of deep
learning and in particular I'm
interested in a
few some topics like how to learn a over
parameterized model meaning that the
number of parameters in the model is
even larger than the number of samples
you have can still do a learning theory
in the setting and also I'm interested
in algorithm regularization in fact like
how an optimization algorithm the
procedure you learn
is a procedure you train the model can
help you can provide some regularization
effect that can help you to generalize
in the over parameters I think and in
particular I mean very interested in
studying gradient descent algorithm and
the stochastic grain is an algorithm uh
so uh yeah in today's Topic in today's
talk I will be focused on gradient
descent a very specific problem in these
topics
okay so
in case of people here are not familiar
with steep learning let me briefly go
through the high level idea of deep
learning so what is deep learning it is
just some new Arts of fitting data
so let's say you have a I have an image
I I have a I know it's labeled I think I
think this image should be dog instead
of glasses so what I do is like I have I
come up with a uh over a very flexible
model okay and then I'm gonna tune the
parameters in this model such as the
output of this model makes the same
prediction as I I wanted it to be okay
then I I repeat this procedure for tons
of data okay hopefully hopefully this
model uh after seeing so many data and
this label hopefully they can generalize
on an unseen new data so that's uh
pretty much the high level idea of a
deep learning and so how do we feed this
data in specific the common recipe is to
do great and decent okay it's a very
old-fashioned algorithm that's back to
Kashi in
1947. so the idea of gradient descent is
a very simple I grab I grab a data and
it's labeled and then I make a ask my
model to make a prediction about the
data okay and then I calculate the the
distance between the current the current
model prediction and the targeted label
and then I make an update about my model
according to the negative gradient
Direction so this way this way I'm
guaranteed to improve to decent the
distance between my prediction and the
target label after doing after repeating
these procedures hopefully I will find a
good model that can fit all of my data
okay
so uh
yeah this is a very nice and the
gradient method has been used in pretty
much every Uh current deep learning
model pretty much everything is trained
by brilliant descent or its variant but
how why this algorithm works so well uh
this is uh this problem is far from
being fully understood so today I'm
gonna focusing on one specific mystery
about gradient descent that is how to
choose the suitable step size ingredient
isn't
okay so when I uh when I introduce the
gradient descent method I actually
missed a import very important recipe
that is in step four uh we want to make
an update of the model along the
negative gradient Direction how much
update should we make okay
so
okay so in other words what is the step
side should I choose in the gradient
descent update rule okay let's first ask
this question to a series okay uh what a
serification will do it will uh the
serialization will run some run some
equations okay uh let's say let's say uh
our model is parameterized by W and we
have a bunch of we have a bunch of data
and then we can write down a uh a
objective now we want to find the W such
that such that it minimizes this uh this
objective okay and then we write down
the gradient Descent of the rule and and
then let's do some math let's plug in
this gradient One Step gradient update
to our objective and then let's do a
Taylor Taylor approximation uh uh then
then you find that okay if the substance
data is small enough then the green box
is a positive quantity that means every
time you wrong a gradient step you are
guaranteed to decrease your objective by
some
by some amount okay and that okay this
is very nice then um then I can write
down write a theory paper and it has a
theorem says that if the snapshot is
small enough then uh L of WT will
decrease monotonically and then I I
proved that gradient descent will work
very nice and I get a theory paper
so okay this is very nice then let's
let's let's try again and ask this
question to a practitioner okay what a
practitioner will do it will run some
numbers let's let's do a very simple
naive experiment that's just to try a
very uh simple fully connected neural
network okay and grab a few grab a
thousand samples from a very simple data
set at least and then let's use gradient
descent to fit this data set uh okay
let's uh let's conduct some experiment
you see you see you see the green curve
green curve uh represents the loss of
the loss of doing uh the loss of
gradient descent with a small subsides
the record represents the gradient
descent loss with a large substance okay
so it seems small steps as it works but
the launch steps also works and and even
it works even better in the long run
okay so then
sorry
anyways so uh then you see you see there
is a gap between the
oops
some of my slides is kept
yeah then you can write down then you
can write a deep learning paper okay you
claim that the large substance works
better and why because I try the three
different random state it all works
better than most websites
this is uh okay then you get a deep
learning paper but there is a huge gap
between the series paper and the Deep
learning paper right you see the Deep
learning paper tells you you should run
very large subsets and where the loss
actually can oscillate but but it works
in the long run somehow but the theory
paper says that okay you should do you
should do small Steps either you are
guaranteed to converge but and and
moreover you can run a Minima probably
the series paper will contain a Mini Max
result it will construct in a hard hard
example such that in the worst case if
you do a large subset you will diverge
the loss Will Never converge but these
two things seems to be there's a there's
a huge gap of your team what happens in
deep learning and the what the what the
theory people will tell us so so
um so
what can we do to fill this Gap it turns
out it turns out that there is no
contradiction just that the the existing
Theory what we what we known before does
not explain does not explain what
happens in practice okay so it's
actually there's there is a very simple
fix to Theory to cover what happens in
practice that let's say let's make some
uh assumption to make our life easier
let's say let's assume the neural
network is very simple it's just a
linear neuron now one layer linear
problem linear model
and and let's assume the data set can be
perfectly fitted then then it can be
sure that if you run gradient descent
with any constant step size you can
still converge despite that the risk
might that might oscillate in the
beginning it will converge in the long
run okay
so why this happens uh the initiation is
that the Lost landscape is not quadratic
at all because we are using Logistics we
are using cross entropy we never use
it's a classification problem
so let me show you a cartoon uh about
the Lost landscape so those landscape
but more likely will be a open Valley
where along One Direction
uh the loss along One Direction the loss
will decrease uh
go go along One Direction you will
decrease the loss but along the other
direction the ship is like a a quadratic
thing so so we run gradient descent with
a large subsides in this large landscape
there will be two forces fighting each
other one force drag you down the valley
the other force causes oscillation uh
along the along the you know the
decrease in Direction so when the other
Force Wings against the force that drags
you down then you observe a risk
increasing
but eventually the the effect of the
force dragging it down this this effect
will accumulate along the optimization
iterations but the other force will
cancel each other their effect so in the
long run
um
uh
uh large substance gradient descent can
still go down the valley
so yeah that's pretty much the intuition
and regarding the question uh I I in the
beginning of the talk I I claimed that I
wanted to
study how how to choose a step size
butter it turns out I haven't answered
this question I just assured that okay
you can run large services and you are
you can still converge but why large
steps that works better than most of
that this is still an open problem until
now so that's uh uh that's all thank you
[Applause]
so any questions yeah
so just to be sure the last plot says
something about numerical instability or
you say that
ETA equals 10 and in a model that this
is a non-convex optimization in some
training is that correct uh this part is
collapsed this is for linear model oh
the priority okay and so you say that
foreign
[Music]
descent then you shouldn't do a very
large Snapchat I see I see but if you
only allowed to run 10 steps of credit
design you should use most of them okay
thanks
the point yeah
uh yeah
how much should you rely on just this
linear assumption you know is it
explanatory for
a more complex loss functions
what is the take
[Music]
I mean it's so simple in some ways maybe
yes how much can it generalize
cool question uh how much I can I think
the intuition in this picture should be
generalizable but the analyze techniques
um needs to be reduced
so even for quadratic there's no proof
for Karate for karate the large steps as
it doesn't work because it will be
probably downward that's a hard case in
in the optimization Theory but it turns
out you give learning because you are
all over parameterized they're pretty
much always in this direction where you
can like go along that direction to
further decrease the loss
so what would be the next like model to
study mathematically after a linear if
you have a candidate
um I mean this model is still in here
but just the last function it's not a
quadratic
it's like a cross entropy type
okay yeah
he's sort of a classic econometrics
literature if I have more uh parameters
than I have observations uh then there's
no close form for for even just a linear
model like this
um whereas my understanding of this is
that you know so long as I use gradient
descent and any constant step size I can
get the true parameters from a linear
case
is that
am I understanding that correctly
uh uh yes this serum says uh uh great
and decent will find the optimal
parameter
what's your question
I guess I'm just saying like it feels
very counter-intuitive to me to be able
to get exactly what the parameter values
are uh when I have more parameters and
observations because you know the
classic result from econometrics is that
oh you know I don't if if I have more
parameters and observations like yeah I
can't identify them yeah okay I say or
questions so the global minimizers are
are are not unique there is there is a
set of global minimizers but their loss
the loss induced by the global
minimizers are the same so gradient
diesel will find one of them in that set
foreign
okay so so next uh Emmanuel